yes afterwards programs on our website
book tv.org
and now the final author presentation
for the day is about to begin
this is author David daily and he's
written a book called rat effed the true
story behind the secret plan to steal
America's democracy there could be
language that some may find offensive in
this presentation this is live coverage
on book TV
annual Chicago Tribune printers roll it
fests I want to give a special thank you
to all our sponsors the theme of this
year's festival is what's your story and
we encourage you to share the stories
you hear this weekend on Twitter
Instagram or Facebook using hashtag PRL
f/16 you can keep the spirit of lit fest
going all year by downloading the
printers ro app where you'll find all of
the Chicago Tribune's premium books
content free and discount ebooks for
subscribers and the complete printers
roll it fest schedule download today to
get a free e-book and five dollars off
flip fest merchandise today's program
will be broadcast live on c-span 2's
book TV if there's time at the end for a
Q&A session with the author we ask you
to use the microphone located to your
right so that the home viewing audience
can hear your questions before we begin
today's program we ask that you silence
your cellphone's and turn off your
camera flashes please welcome associate
professor at the University of Chicago
and today's interviewer Jane Daly hi
thank you I am here with David Daly no
relation who is the editor-in-chief of
salon and has published this new book
there's been some controversy on how to
say the title but I think I'm just going
to say rat effed the true story behind
the secret plan to steal America's
democracy so that's quite a story
but you tell us a bit about how you came
to write this story absolutely thank you
what really interested me was my own
confusion over what happened in 2012 you
have a president who was reelected 332
electoral votes to 206 wins the popular
vote by some 3.5 million the Democrats
take 25 of 33 Senate seats that were up
that year they win the popular vote
or the House of Representatives in the
aggregate by 1.4 million and that moved
seven seats and the Republicans retained
a 235 to 205 majority and as we all know
the house had become the the key
obstructionist lever on in the
Republican plan to block the Obama
agenda and this was the first time since
1972 that the party that won the most
votes in the aggregate did not as a
result take control of the chamber and I
was curious to find out why and as you
look into it you understand that there
was an active plan put into place by the
Republicans during the election of 2010
and then followed up during the
remapping of 2011 that radically
reinvented gerrymandering in a brand-new
way and used it as a blunt tool of
partisan force and remapped America
right so you're saying you know every 10
years we have the Census the
congressional district lines are redrawn
and you say something this is something
that happens every 10 years but you're
saying that what happened in 2010 was
different in kind from all of the other
decennial remapping 's 0 years always
reverberate longer across the political
landscape because the census mandates
that every seat in state and federal
legislative bodies be redrawn based on
population and gerrymandering as a tool
goes back to 1790 it's an ancient
political dark art and has been used by
both parties throughout that time you
know sometimes in roguish ways
as an incumbent protection racket other
times as a way to shiv a political enemy
but what happened in 2010 was
fundamentally different from any of the
previous gerrymanders over the last two
hundred and ten years it's a combination
of the dark money unleashed by citizens
united it's brand new technological
mapping tools that allow you to draw
these lines with precision that you
could have never before imagined I mean
think of the different ways we texted
each other in 2000 versus the way we did
on a smartphone in 2010 and that is the
kind of advances that you saw in mapping
technology over those years between 1990
and 2000 even in those years you're
still using parchment to you know draw
these lines and then slow computers and
the technological weapons available
changed it as did a really brilliant
strategy by a handful of Republican
strategists so let's talk a little bit
about about that strategy and also about
what kind of data they're putting into
these into these programs because it's
not just how many registered voters
there are how many you know how many
people and you're supposed to just count
the people right so tell us a little bit
about who who are these people behind
the 2010 gerrymander and what's the data
that they're working with what you have
to do is you have to go back to the
night that Barack Obama is elected
president 2008 right down the road here
in Grant Park there's a tremendous
celebration and on television that night
everybody pronounced the Republican
Party dead that the looming demographics
were going to roll them over 2008 was
the fourth that presidential election
out of five that they lost the popular
vote on TV even the Republican pundits
are wringing their hands and disbelief
at what has happened the following
summer a Christian Kowski who is a
brilliant southern
just at something called the Republican
State Leadership Committee is reading a
story in The New York Times and he comes
across a note about how the 2010 is a
census year and what he already knows is
that you know presidents attend to lose
seats in a midterm year and he says boy
if I could understand the redistricting
process in all of these states and if I
could raise the money to go in and
influence and flip state legislative
chambers state-by-state we could
radically alter the map we're fighting
on and when you draw the map you make
the rules and that is what they did they
identified about eight states that well
there there were many more than that but
there were about eight states in which
they had the most impact and these are
essentially you know blue or purple
states like Ohio and Michigan and
Wisconsin North Carolina Florida and in
some ways it was the greatest political
heist in history because for just thirty
million dollars that's all it cost they
were able to go in and run negative ads
in all of these you know small state
legislative districts that were not used
to seeing that kind of money come in and
for a song they were able to draw new
maps and build themselves a firewall or
the next decade so first they used the
money they hire they elected all of
these Republicans to the state
legislature yes and then those people
and those people in 2011 once you had
control of the Chamber's and control of
the process in each of these individual
states they hired brilliant mapping
firms and people who really understand
how every line matters and I would
happen drove a bunch of these districts
and you can see turn-by-turn exactly why
they did some of the things they did you
know on a map when you look at some of
these districts they seem insane you
know it looks like a Rorschach test of
some sort but the actual true meaning
and intent of it all when you get close
up is is staggering so you make a strong
claim in the book that the intent behind
the Republican redistricting process was
not simply to protect incumbents which
is the old-fashioned way you know
politicians they don't like competition
they don't like to have to run for
reelection every two years they'd rather
have a safe seat and that's I think
we've seen instances of that certainly
by both parties in the past but you're
making a bigger claim than that you're
you're suggesting that they went the
Republican operatives who did this went
in with the intent to erode popular
democracy the goal was nothing less than
to build a firewall against popular
democracy yes and it held because in
2012 again 1.4 million more people vote
for Democratic candidates than
Republican candidates and they managed
to hold on to the house
thanks to this plan that they enacted
when Americans go to the voting booths
and they express disfavor
with the party in power and nothing
happens
that's the deeply dangerous problem for
a participatory democracy so you have a
story about how the districts are done
you use one in North Carolina district
that has Asheville in it and can you can
you tell us so one of the one of the
things that seems to have happened
particularly in the south is that
moderate Southern Democrats which is
almost always synonymous with white
Southern Democrats in that part of the
country have become extinct it's true
they're pretty much entirely gone
there has been a two-part strategy that
turned the South Republican the first
piece of this begins in 1989 1990 when
Lee Atwater takes over the helm of the
Republican National Committee any he
hires a new a new council named Ben
Ginsberg and he tells Ben Ginsberg we're
gonna do something about redistricting
and what they come up with was dubbed
the unholy alliance it was it was an
alliance between between black Democrats
in the South who were eager to increase
their representation in Congress and
Republicans with a lot of money and
really newfangled computer programs and
they worked together in many states in
order to what was the interest of the
black black Democrats working I mean it
does sound like an unholy alliance well
they were able to build the
african-american caucus in Congress to
the the highest level since after
reconstruction in 1992 1994 but the cost
of that was that the Republicans took
many more seats so a state like North
Carolina which had been eight for
Democrats with the twelve members you
know suddenly flips eight for the other
way right and you pack all of the
Democratic voters into a couple of
districts you give yourself the rest
right so and that's because of the
Voting Rights Act the Voting Rights Act
that you want to have these majority
minority districts so the you end up
with all the black Democrats put into
one circle and then everybody else and
you're saying you're suggesting that the
black Democrats actively cooperated with
that plan in many cases they did and you
can understand why they were you know
tired - I mean african-americans where
they probably one of the most essential
voting blocks in the Democratic Party
but they were
erratically under-represented but it's a
complicated arrangement and there's an
there's and there's winners and losers
involved right so let's talk about some
of the the winners and losers because
one of the big losers right at the
moment looks like the Republican Party
itself as you talked talked to me about
the unintended consequences of some of
this this grand this grand strategy for
the Republican Party well I think that
what happened was they created a caucus
that they could not control and you
mentioned Asheville what happened in
Asheville
in 2010 Asheville is represented by a
moderate conservative Democrat named
Heath Shuler when they redraw the lines
Schuler takes a look at this districts
as I can't win here knows it retires he
is replaced by a tea party conservative
named mark meadows who runs on a you
know very you know angry campaign
against Barack Obama this suggests you
was born in in Kenya and he wants to
send him back there it's a horrible ugly
campaign a meadows wins this district
which is created because they cracked
Asheville in half and put half of the
Democratic votes and in one city it I'm
sorry in one district and then and then
at the others and - exactly
it's called cracking and meadows that
gets elected and he becomes the renegade
Republican who makes the parliamentary
move that ends up in the ouster of John
Boehner this is where it gets good
so essentially what happened is the
Republicans create non-competitive
districts across the country in which
the only election that matters is the
Republican primary and as a result you
end up with a different breed of
Congressman and they were not
controllable by John Boehner
and they are barely controllable now but
by Paul Ryan and the tenor and the tone
of Congress changes when elections don't
matter all right so these are the guys
and I think they are guys pretty much
almost and they are also all white yes
the other and disproportionately from
the south these are the people who
brought you let's let's shut down the
government over the debt ceiling let's
shut down the government
let's have 51 votes on Obama right
exactly the scare trying over to
investigate a Benghazi again and again
right and then it came to let's overturn
John Boehner as the Speaker of our party
you talked with with Meadows a bit about
the tenor of the elections and the
language that's become common for this
really quite extreme faction of the
Republican Party which seems now to
become the core of the Republican Party
when you've got people like meadow
saying you know you can elect me we're
gonna send Barack Obama back to Kenya
that seems to me like it just creates a
nice path for person with orange hair
alright our presumptive nominee I think
that the full term for him is the result
of Republican nominee as if no one can
really quite bring themselves to
actually say it yes no I think that's
exactly right I think you can draw a
line from the lines that they redrew in
Congress to the presumptive nomination
of Donald Trump the Republican Party
empowered their angriest whitest base
they purged all the moderates and they
created these districts that are so
non-competitive that you do not have to
speak to the rest of the country we've
lost the art of persuasion of
of trying to convince somebody else that
your case is is correct and now that we
are down to a dangerous you know handful
of competitive districts in this country
I mean maybe it's two dozen you you
don't have to talk to anybody on the
other side so you can completely
understand how an angry white base might
want to build a wall that is a beautiful
and huge so you talk about this being a
Republican strategy and it wasn't you
know a grand Republican strategy they
were gonna take the house perpetually
they were going to then elect a
Republican president that Republican
president with the Senate would enact
the House agenda you said the the Paul
Ryan agenda we have Grover Norquist puts
it puts it very nicely about looking at
at at 2012 he says okay looking at 2016
all that Republicans have to do he says
we just need a president to sign this
stuff pick a Republican with enough
working digits to handle a pen to become
President of the United States that's
the strategy how's it work how's it
working out for them they thought it was
gonna work out perfectly Paul Ryan
thought that he could be President as
Speaker of the House essentially right
on and it hasn't happened first you have
a caucus that may or may not even be on
board with elements of the Ryan agenda
and then essentially all of the
presidents with working digits to handle
a pen that the establishment favored
whether that was Jeb Bush or Chris
Christie or John Kasich or Marco Rubio
or Scott Walker any of the people who
they thought would essentially execute
the Ryan agenda from the other side of
Pennsylvania Avenue we saw how they did
write another crashed and burned
now they've got a nominee with small
hands holding and I think that that in
some ways is the real concern that the
Republican Party has with Donald Trump
right now
I think it is probably naive to think
that the party that created the Southern
Strategy is all that upset at what he
calls a judge on what concerns them is
that they don't know if he will execute
the Ryan agenda if elected and it seems
like one one issue that we've certainly
been seeing with with the Republican
Party this year is reluctance to
acknowledge the separation of powers in
our in our Republican with a smaller our
Republican government so we have a
Senate that will not give a hearing to a
Supreme Court nominee nominee
you know nominated and as per the
Constitution by a sitting president we
have a president who has resorted to
stretching some of the executive powers
in the face of a Congress that won't do
anything that he wants it's Donald Trump
is promising the impossible to the
people who are voting from before him
you know he just stands up and says I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that and they
seem to either believe it or like it
you've got it you know people are
comparing him to as a strongman which is
apparently what the voters for him want
well I think that successive waves of
more deeply conservative Republicans
have made these promises that they were
going to take care of Obamacare they
were going to do something about
immigration and it didn't happen
now it didn't happen because of
separation of powers but it didn't
happen and they kept winning majorities
they kept winning elections but they
never delivered on any of the things
that they said they were going to
deliver on even after rigging the game
entirely the right so as a result that
angry base gets even angrier and
somebody comes along and says I'm gonna
do this and
people are willing to give that a listen
but people are also not interested in
the Jeb's and the cases and the other
Republican candidates who crashed and
burned this year they had seen that that
before they didn't trust it they didn't
buy it so again you talk about this as a
strategy for the Republicans they went
into this with the goal of permanently
maintaining control on the house which
requires renunciation of participatory
democracy did they seem you talked to
these two these people the the the
architects of this do they seem bothered
by the fact that they're under my
undermining participatory democracy in
the United States they think they were
doing their jobs I mean frankly um you
know Chris Pat Jankowski is a a
gentleman who spent a lot of time with
me knowing I had you know differing
political opinions then he did he holds
um and I asked him that question I'm
like well is this fair and he says yes I
was doing my job
the other side was not doing theirs and
he's completely right about that it this
was a catastrophic strategic failure on
the part of the Democratic Party they
did not have the imagination or vision
to see this coming
even when karl rove announces the
strategy and the pages of the Wall
Street Journal in March of 2010 he says
we are going into the state legislative
districts with the goal of effecting a
redistricting next year I mean maybe the
Democrats don't read that The Wall
Street Journal I don't know hopefully
they're all they're all reading Salon
yeah where were you guys on this story
so they simply did not plan they I mean
Jankowski tells me that in September and
October he's wondering where the
Democrats are he's out in all of these
states spending money working on camp
then there is no opposition the Steve
Israel who took over the Democratic
campaign committee after this debacle
for the Democrats in 2011 tells me the
DNC was whistling past the graveyard
they did not have the strategic mind to
comprehend what was happening or the
ability to block it even when the demek
when the Republican Party announced the
plan in big flashing neon lights that's
that's disturbing I mean you do wonder
what the Democrats are thinking or what
their what they're doing or why it's
malpractice it's yeah political
malpractice so by our Democratic leaders
like Nancy Pelosi why didn't they do
anything well on one hand I think they
lack the imagination to see this because
it hadn't been done before so perhaps
they simply didn't imagine it um but I
mean Nancy Pelosi is in a very safe
district Nancy Pelosi doesn't have to
think really about redistricting the
Democrats who over the years did raise
alarms about this or guys like John
Tanner of Tennessee or Martin frost from
Texas they were Democrats in southern
states who recognized what was happening
and wanted to do something about it done
you know Nancy Pelosi and Steny Hoyer
were you know less interested in it and
they had opportunities I mean John
Tanner had a you know a national
nonpartisan redistricting plan that he
introduced I believe three congresses in
a row including the two that the
Democrats were in charge of at the end
of the of the 2000s and he told me Nancy
Pelosi and Steny Hoyer just wouldn't
even give him the time of day on it they
had they had no interest in the issue at
all it's I don't know if it's clear that
Congress can actually do this
elections are really controlled at the
state level so winning all of those
state legislatures seems to have been
the absolutely crucial piece along with
I understand judges who would rule on
these things to make sure that they went
their way which is also the really
interesting thing about
this is at exactly how many levels
they've affected the game the system has
been locked in about four or five
different places and it will take a lot
of different keys and a long long time
to undo what was done in 2010 and 2011
this this is not a single cycle problem
it's not a single state problem that
this has had a huge impact across the
country and it has to be undone in each
of those states one legislative chamber
at a time how we now that they've built
themselves in how do you do that I mean
how do you get out of this locked circle
it's almost it's almost impossible to
imagine and the Democrats in their usual
strategic blundering are going about it
by trying to run the same play that the
Republicans did in 2010 they have
something called advantage 2020 that
they are trying to raise seventy million
dollars for to do the same thing except
they'll be running it on Republican maps
with less money and with no element of
surprise it's not going to work it's an
element for failure on there are a
handful of things that could be done um
whenever I think voters understand that
this is a serious problem and voters of
both parties want elections to matter
they want votes to count that they
believe in the idea of participatory
democracy and are bothered by the fact
that a result you know doesn't doesn't
hold up doesn't count and in states
where non partisan redistricting has
gone to a referendum and this includes
red states and blue states Arizona
Florida California Ohio it passes in in
large numbers um so that is is one
possible
root there are also some you know really
interesting election reforms some of
which you know feel very very radical
and different the idea of you know
multi-member districts or ranked choice
voting but you know a lot of those are
being used in more and more cities
across the country and as people become
comfortable with them as ideas that's
another way around this but it's going
to take a lot of different keys to undo
this there's also the possibility of a
Supreme Court case that you know could
the rule on this the court over the
years has not chosen to ever that
disavow a partisan gerrymandering
however Anthony Kennedy has suggested
that he's open to a standard if just
disable one could be shown to him so
there's a handful of cases right now
where you know smart people are
attempting to define a standard that
might appeal to Justice Kennedy
well there was Justice Scalia even who
said look if partisan gerrymandering
gets out of control it's a threat to
democracy which it really seems to be
him we were talking before and I said it
sounds terribly partisan having this
conversation because it's all dumped on
the Republicans dumped on the
Republicans but in the spirit of dumping
on the Republicans there's another facet
to this which is the disenfranchisement
campaigns that the Republican Party has
been waging in the name of anti-fraud
there's no evidence of fraud in any of
the places that they have made these
arguments the the you know photo ID laws
the limited hours all of these things
are designed to reduce the electorate
which goes along with their I have such
a hard time believing that this is
really their goal because we've been
there before in this country and it
hasn't worked out very well there was
the famous autopsy after the 2012
election when Republicans lost that v
out of sixth popular vote at the
presidential level and they said we have
to
something different we have to appeal to
Latino voters we have to appeal to
minority voters that's not in the end
the path they chose the path they chose
instead was to try to block those votes
and then pack those voters into fewer
and fewer districts it's it's you know
we're gonna open up to the audience for
questions in a minute but it's
tremendously disturbing to see all of
this and part of that I think goes to
some of the anger of the Trump voters
because when people feel like they don't
have a chance to win next time you know
you can lose this round because there's
always a chance four years from now
you're gonna have a chance to win maybe
they'll do what you wanted them to do
but I can even see the Trump voters
being frustrated with the same process
and the Sanders voters as well yes very
much there is you know a surge of voter
anger and one of the reasons is because
the system has been intentionally
sabotage not to work right but when you
get to that point it's it's a very
dangerous one
it's it's it's extraordinarily dangerous
when when majorities at the at the
ballot box are arranged in ways to make
them look like they are not majorities
it it's not democracy no it's when
government of the people by the people
and for the people ceases to exist then
you don't then you don't have a republic
anymore
well on that note there's some questions
from the audience
so first I'll say I'm really glad I
stuck around to the very end of the day
to hear this thank you very very
interesting and I can't wait to read
your book
so as I'm listening and learning I'm
thinking about a book I recently read C
Street about the fundamentalist threat
to democracy and I'm curious if they
that you've been talking about are those
fundamentalists in the Republican Party
and is there really that threat to our
democracy for enemy
I guess the imposition of religion in
our government I don't think that the
people who were behind these strategies
were especially motivated by that I mean
I think that if you look at the people
who were most directly involved in read
map it it comes out of something called
the Republican State Leadership
Committee which is a very establishment
a concern and what was run by Ed
Gillespie who was a former chair of the
party a candidate for Senate in Virginia
they were working you know in hand
essentially with American Crossroads
Karl Rove's group they were funded by
the big Republican funders the Chamber
of Commerce and Altria and at Walmart
and AT&T so essentially this was the
establishment wing of the party
attempting to lock in control so that
they could govern from the house and
also so they could create a laboratory
for conservative ideas and state
capitals across the country I think it's
important also to you know think about
that when you and this reverberates at
that level as well when you look at you
know something like the transgender
bathroom bill in North Carolina which
you know I think that the poll shows 60%
of people there's our against I mean
that is the kind of bill that comes out
when you have a gerrymander districts
and non-accountable
a minority in
charge right I mean you talk about that
in the book if you look at statistics
are with Americans on gun control no
Americans across the board
overwhelmingly favor reasonable gun
control majority of Americans has since
the 1970s supported right to abortion
all of these these issues are not
polarizing issues the people are very
pretty clear when you are on the other
side of those issues and you want to
remain in power you have to change the
rules well that's what this is about
changing the rules what and one of the
things you have in here about again when
you when you change the rules so that
you get only the most extreme someone is
is describing these people as saying
they have their value systems and they
are the right systems and and they will
Brook you know they don't want to hear
about anybody else's value systems and
and that's that certitude is also very
dangerous to democracy I think that's
right I think we see a very different
Republican Party than the one we had ten
years ago that's certainly 20 years ago
so so where what are now the rump
Republicans you know Mitt Romney and and
the Bush family David Brooks and David
Brooks it's a really small room that's
right well some people maybe haven't
coming out you mean what are they gonna
what are they gonna do are they gonna go
to Cleveland and lift of lift the flag
for Donald Trump if their option is
Hillary Clinton yes and they they will
hold the house no matter what happens to
Donald Trump they will hold the house
there will be panels on cable TV for the
next four months talking about can the
Democrats win the house no but the
answer is no and you in some ways need
not even have the elections because the
districts have been crafted so perfectly
and so precisely as to withstand even a
large Democratic Lance
um so they will have the house and they
will have the Senate most likely in
those big states Ohio Pennsylvania the
even if Democrats take those stay so why
not wait and see if if Donald Trump wins
and then they can enact their agenda but
I mean in all of those states I mean I
mean in in in Pennsylvania you had a
hundred thousand more votes for
Democratic House candidates in 2012 than
Republican ones and the Republicans
controlled 13 of the 18 seats so 51
percent of the vote equals 28 percent of
the seats in Michigan in 2012 240,000
more votes for House Democrats than
Republicans
it's a 9-5 Republican administration in
Ohio at the state level you had more
votes for Democratic candidates than
Republican ones the lines were so good
that even in 2012 as Barack Obama takes
Ohio a sherrod Brown wins re-election at
the Democrat the Republicans took a 60
39 supermajority with fewer votes so
that's what the Democrats are up against
so it's not going to change in 2016 so
the Republicans may as well try to see
what happens if they get that president
with a pen Wow
I think we have another question strikes
me that there is another step to this
process the Constitution does not
require that the Electoral College bail
out allotted on a winner-take-all state
by state basis so it's the next step and
we're starting to hear some of this is
the next step to a portion according to
congressional districts which are
adjourned
you're exactly right and that's one of
the really scary things here I mean you
saw this in Pennsylvania in the last
cycle that there were members of the
House in Pennsylvania who said let's
change the way we apportion electoral
college votes and do it by Ingres
districts and then you would have a
state like Pennsylvania that has gone
blue every year I believe
other than nine since I think it went
for four George HW Bush in 88 but it's
been democratic ever since if you were
to apportion those those votes by
congressional district
so 13 of 18 gives you you know two
senators which I believe are one
Democrat one Republican so you would go
fourteen six Republican instead of
instead of twenty or the Democrats and
that would be while being on the
opposite side so you know it's a it's
it's it's it's an amazing way to do the
math well that question um I know it
depends on how it's done but it strikes
me that gerrymandering can make certain
districts vulnerable to a real high
turnout that that is that it goes
against the the way the gerrymander errs
planned you said that a landslide
wouldn't help the Democrats in the
coming election but are there districts
that are vulnerable to an unexpectedly
high turnout and would that not create
an incentive on the party to make that
to publicize that there are some and
there are some states where the Democrat
I'm sorry excuse me where the
Republicans have gotten greedy
especially Texas is a really interesting
case there are a lot of districts in
Texas where they drew the lines based on
modeling of how they believed Latino
voters would turn out so the goal was to
make it look like it was a district that
Democrats could win and that it was a
majority minority seat
except they knew from having all of the
voter registration information that
you can overlay onto the onto the map
titude program that draws these lines
they could have a sense of who would
actually vote and who wouldn't vote on
so if you could find a way to get those
people out there are a handful of
districts that would be vulnerable to a
crushing wave of democratic but of
democratic votes but they're there that
they're few and far between um they used
really really interesting algorithmic
excuse me indexes in all of these states
to draw these lines for the worst-case
scenarios yes this just encourages I
think the kind of we can do anything we
want behavior that you see lately in the
in the Senate and I'm thinking now of
course of what is I think genuinely a
constitutional crisis where we have a
Senate that refuses to consider a
Supreme Court nomination by a sitting
president who has every right to make
that nomination who has put forward an
extremely conciliatory well qualified
moderate nominee and Merrick garland and
they are not giving judge garland the
time of day we have to find a way to
make the system work again the system
has been deeply and profoundly broken
well on that note I think we are about
out of time but we want to thank you all
for coming this afternoon it is late in
the day and please do buy the book on
the way out and give it to your father's
for Father's Day and give it to your
friends and neighbors and book club
people and thank you so much for
supporting printers row
this kid thanks for today
burger today didn't in this book as miss
miss will be upfront and we really
appreciate feedback please take a minute
to visit printers rule attest at work
and submit your post event survey thanks
[Music]
and that concludes book TVs live
coverage of the 32nd annual printers
road lit fest in Chicago all of the
events from today will re-air beginning
at 1:00 a.m. Eastern Time